hi youtube this is eyeshadow bethesda
Regional Director for Intel for Middle
East turkey and Africa I think role
models are extremely important we as
Intel tried a role model particularly in
the area of Education what we're trying
to show to the rest of the world is
every kid deserves an opportunity to use
the pc and technology and that they can
do wonderful things with it this is why
Intel is so dedicated to incorporating
pasting into the education space and
this is why we have trained over 600,000
teachers in this region alone to make
sure that they actually train the
students the 21st century skills and
they become role models for the students
and their communities and actually show
that they're ahead of the game just like
in the rest of the world they can bring
that goodness of Technology and make
sure that they educate our kids or in
the future of the right way